tu madame le jury est maintenant au
complet
vous n'en fait pas partie
[Musique]
on
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est quelqu'un
[Musique]
à quel moment ça a merdé
dans vos carrières non dire que vous
êtes là vous êtes au au festival de
cannes mais clairement pas du bon côté
la notion d' ombre et lumière là est
forte ce soir le
je sais pas ce que beaucoup d'entre vous
ont participé à des films alors posons
nous les bonnes questions
je vois des acteurs car un mastroianni
la grande cécile de france aussi des
gens extraordinaires qui sont là soit
des metteurs en scène même des
talentueux joua les producteurs voient
des techniciens
j'aurais beaucoup de gens qui ont
participé à des films ses films était-il
si bon
qui sommes nous pour dire ce qui est bon
ou mauvais enfin voilà bonne soirée à
tous bien sûr avec ce questions sans
réponse qui nous permet de vivre plus
intensément